Buildings are not only what they seem.
They aren't just inert structures
to live and work in.
They're connected to the energy system.
And this makes buildings
an essential element
of the efforts to decarbonize our world.
Today, I want to talk
about changing our thinking
around the role of buildings
in the energy system
and how they can transform
to bring us closer to our climate targets.
But first, I want to take you
to where I grew up,
in this building
in a mid-sized city in Russia.
To me, it looked [like]
just a great concrete box,
like many others.
There are indeed numerous buildings
like this across Europe and Central Asia,
inherited from Soviet times.
They were built quickly
to house as many people as possible,
without much consideration
for their design,
comfort and energy usage.
This is true of many, many buildings
across the world.
Nondescript housing and office boxes,
built fast and cheap,
and all connected to the energy system.
I live in Paris now,
and though buildings there
look much nicer,
from the perspective of energy,
issues are similar.
High energy consumption,
reliance on fossil fuels
and high energy costs,
driven even higher
by the current energy crisis.
In Paris, I work
with International Energy Agency,
and we advise governments across the world
on various energy issues.
And for that, we look at data a lot.
And our data shows
that at the global scale,
buildings are responsible for about
one third of total energy consumption
and energy- and process-related
carbon dioxide emissions.
In Europe, for example,
90 percent of buildings that exist today
will still be standing and in use by 2050.
We are also building more new buildings.
Our data shows that the global floor area
is expected to increase
by 75 percent by mid-century.
This is equivalent to adding
an area the size of Paris every week
for the next 30 years.
If this happens with energy
consumption patterns of today,
this alone will make it very difficult
to achieve our climate targets.
Fortunately, we do have
solutions available
to reduce direct emissions from buildings
by more than 95 percent by 2050.
And for this, we need three things:
efficiency,
electrification and decarbonization.
Energy efficiency must come first.
And in buildings,
it should be improved in two ways.
First, through improving energy efficiency
of the building envelope
with better materials, design solutions,
insulation of walls, roofs, basements,
energy-efficient windows.
Second, through improving
energy efficiency
of all appliances and equipment
used in building --
for space heating and cooling,
water heating,
lighting, cooking,
working and entertainment.
However, energy efficiency,
as they say, takes a village.
Many forces and interests interact
during construction
and renovation of a building.
The developers, the owners,
the regulators, the architects,
the suppliers of technologies,
the market itself exerting price pressure.
All these need to be aligned.
And it all starts
with the governments mandating
minimum energy efficiency requirements
through their regulation,
putting the right incentives in place
and providing clear information tools.
Building energy codes,
standards and labeling for appliances
and equipment, as well as buildings,
are among the most effective
instruments at our disposal --
if they're enforced well and together
with other supporting mechanisms.
Energy efficiency in buildings
also depends on us as consumers,
the choices we make,
buildings we decide to live in,
appliances and devices we buy
and the way we use them
at home or our workplaces.
So what is the result
of improving energy efficiency?
Significant energy savings,
reduced CO2 emissions,
lower energy bills
and improved comfort, productivity
and health of people living in them.
The second thing we need
is a massive shift towards electricity.
And of course I mean
clean, decarbonized electricity
produced from solar, wind
and other low-carbon sources.
If we look at Europe, for instance,
more than 40 percent of households
rely on natural gas
for space heating and cooking.
To complicate matters,
40 percent of all gas consumed in Europe
last year was imported from Russia.
So there is a climate imperative,
but also a strong geopolitical
and energy security imperative
to electrify and decarbonize our buildings
and make them as efficient as possible.
This doesn't only mean replacing
energy supply from a gas pipeline
with energy supply from an electric line.
And here I reach back to my opening point.
We need to look at buildings differently.
Not only as great concrete boxes,
as I used to do,
but as potential active players
in the energy system.
So how can we make buildings active?
Through installing efficient
and low-carbon technologies
such as solar panels,
heat pumps, energy storage,
making use of smart and digital tools.
All technologies we already have,
and in many cases
their costs are decreasing.
Let me introduce a word
we don’t often hear:
“prosumer.”
Think of a building not only
as a consumer of energy,
but as prosumer,
both consuming and producing.
Most buildings can produce
at least part of the energy they need.
In many cases, they can produce more.
Such buildings already exist
in many parts of the world.
In Switzerland, for example,
there is even a single family house
that produces 800 percent
of the energy it needs.
But still, we have a long way to go
to make them a common practice.
Besides challenges
with improving energy efficiency
and installing low-carbon technologies,
another obstacle is
that our electricity networks,
or grids, as we call them,
were designed to operate
with large centralized sources
of generation, like power plants.
And their design hasn't changed much
over the past century.
So increasing decentralized
or distributed, smaller-scale generation,
especially from variable
renewable sources like solar and wind,
can really put pressure
on existing electricity grids
and challenge their stability.
So we also need to rethink the way
our entire electricity system is designed.
Smart grids can communicate to a building
through software algorithms
and smart controls,
and, for example, send a signal
to a connected device,
such as your heating system,
to temporarily stop or reduce energy use,
or, if possible, shift it to the time
when electricity is more available,
cleaner or cheaper.
This can really improve the robustness
of the electricity network
and help to avoid,
for example, rolling blackouts,
which are becoming more common,
while consumers can get paid for it.
If you have an electric car
and you keep it plugged in
for a prolonged period of time,
a smart charger can help to find
the best time to charge it,
depending on the information
from the grid.
This can help save you money
and support the electricity system.
It gets even more interesting.
Electric cars are essentially
batteries on wheels,
so they can also be used as energy storage
and dispatch electricity
to the home or to the grid
at the time of need.
A building itself can be used
to store energy for some time,
but you need to make it
energy-efficient first.
Potentially you can also get paid
for making your energy storage available
for electricity system
to store renewable electricity
when there is too much of it,
for example, when there is
a lot of sunshine or wind,
but demand is not
high enough to use it all.
It's almost like renting
your spare bedroom on Airbnb,
just for hosting electricity.
Now imagine a future
with many, many buildings,
solar panels, electric cars,
energy storage, other distributed devices,
drawing electricity from the grid
and supplying electricity back to it.
Obviously we would need a way
to manage all this data efficiently
and in real time,
make sure that devices
interact well with each other
and are able to communicate to the grid
and optimize electricity demand
and supply for the entire system.
Virtual power plants,
digital and intelligent platforms
can do just that.
They can aggregate
electricity consumption and production
from many distributed resources,
make use of local storage
and manage complex interactions.
Virtual power plants can also facilitate
peer-to-peer renewable
electricity trading.
Imagine that electricity
that your building produced,
for example, from solar panels,
but you don't need at the moment,
you can sell directly
to another building that needs it
via an online platform.
A project like this has been running
already for several years
in one of the districts in Bangkok
and is showing benefits to the consumers,
the grid and the planet.
There are other pilot projects like this
in different countries,
but for them to scale,
our policy frameworks
and electricity market design
need to undergo substantial changes.
Our buildings need to become
more efficient
and grids need to evolve
into smarter managers
of distributed energy resources.
It's a dramatic shift.
It's like going from all-television world
with a single broadcaster
to a new, connected world
where everyone can generate
and share their own content.
Remember that building I grew up in?
You might be surprised,
but during winter, it would often get
too hot inside the apartment,
even if it was -30 outside.
It was because of highly inefficient
central heating system,
which we couldn't control
or do anything about.
So we did this.
Yes. We had to open the windows
to get some fresh air and more comfort.
Now I want to take you
to my current flat in Paris,
where I have tiny but very smart boxes
attached to my electric heaters,
which can automatically
turn them on and off,
maintaining comfortable temperatures,
lowering my energy bills
and providing flexibility to the grid.
And I can control all that
on my smartphone.
The technologies -- that we have.
Now we need the policies,
the investments, the will --
and a new way to look at buildings
not just passive users of energy,
but as active players
in the energy system.
Buildings that can consume
and produce energy efficiently,
interact with a smart grid
and respond to its signals,
providing flexibility and bringing us
closer to our climate targets.
Thank you.
(Applause)